hi everyone ted florent here with eight
news now we're continuing our five part
series survival in the desert because a
lot of you are going to be hitting the
trails as the temperatures warm up it's
perfect outside right now joining us is
lana mcveigh she is with red rock search
and rescue highly qualified for this let
us know about uh cell phone service
people grab their cell phones what
should they know before they head out to
the desert do their hiking
well they should know if they've got
cell service or not but they should
always prepare that they don't have cell
service and there's a lot of ways that
they can prepare to go on a hike still
know their navigation still know where
they're going and not have cell phone
service and one way you know is always
to have a garmin or if you have the
capability to have a garment
you have to know how to use your garmin
and you have to have spare batteries for
your garmin device but cells cell phones
smartphones specifically now
have gps capabilities built into them
and a lot of people don't know that but
they have gps capabilities that work
even when the self does not have service
and even when um your point your phone
is in airplane mode
and to use this you have to have a
couple of applications there's a few uh
ones all trails one's
uh
gaia gps one is cal topo another one
it's avenza but these applications
they're pretty cheap especially compared
to garmin devices
you can install them on your phone and
you can use them with or without cell
phone service really
and they uh they provide a lot of other
features
they'll show you where you are exactly
on a map they're very user friendly so
you can see the map on your phone
um you can see exactly where you are on
the map the map will provide your
coordinates so if you ever get in
trouble uh you can um and you have cell
service you can let somebody know your
exact coordinates
they um
you have the capability of
recording your tracks
you the application will tell you how
far you've traveled
how high of elevation gain you had how
long the trail has been
they'll give you all these statistics
um and compared to garmin devices they
really are reasonably priced
now the other thing that people run into
is they the confidence i've got my cell
phone i can go anywhere right uh that's
not the case though because sometimes
cell service does go out it would spot
you when i was out here too what's your
recommendation of people that go out to
a location they get hurt or something
happens and their cell phones go out if
they get hurt if they need help the best
thing they can do is um you know try to
get somebody's attention on the trail
talk to other people if no one else is
around
hopefully they had a plan before they
went out hiking and they provided that
information to somebody if you um
have that plan you give somebody exactly
what time you left what time you expect
to be back where you've gone you stick
with that plan and then if you're an
overdue hiker that person is the one
that will
alert people and let them know where to
start and then you on the trail you stay
where you're at you know we have hug a
tree programs for the kids but in nevada
we do hug a rock because we're kind of
limited on trees so find that spot and
stay with it stay as close to the trail
and just wait somebody will come along
great advice people continuously coming
up going on the trail so stay in one
spot the other question i had for you is
uh there's all different types of hikes
here mount charleston everywhere but
they're not for every single person talk
about the the hikes people should go on
the strenuous hikes what should people
look for before they take these heights
well again there's some great resources
out there on the web and in the
applications
where you can pre-plan and pre-research
a hike before you go
another it's all trails again gaia gps
again another one is called burden hike
and they'll give you information about
um the strenuous
part of the trail you know if it's easy
if it's moderate if it's difficult it'll
let you know if there's scrambles
required if it's going to be flat like
this if there's shale involved or if
there's other difficulties on the trail
such as if you have to climb a rope or a
ladder so whenever you plan a hike with
a group of people you need to plan for
the um the least experienced person on
your hike and always look out for each
other you know
lynn in part one pointed out a lot of
things so you look out for each other
and look for those heat related injuries
and for elevation sickness for
dehydration signs and carry that extra
water for each other you made a good
point is before you head out even as
you're a group you think you're safe but
you should let people know where you're
at where you're going correct that is
correct and if your
loved one is a hiker be part of his plan
insist that you know where they're going
what time they're leaving and what time
they need to come back that way you can
make that first call for assistance on
the trail and if somebody deviates from
that plan that adds a significant amount
of time to locating them and providing
assistance
great thank you so much appreciate it
and uh thank you to red rock search and
rescue for being part of this five part
series on survivability in the desert
thank you so much and hopefully you guys
got some great advice
you